pooja had a beautiful plant the plant
began sprouting two days before pooja
bought it and she had it for 98 days
before it died at its tallest the plant
was 30 centimeters tall all right let H
of T denote the height of poojas plant H
measured in centimeters T days from the
time she bought it which number type is
more appropriate for the domain of the
function and they tell us whether it's
integers or real numbers so we just have
to remind ourselves the domain of a
function that's the set of all the
inputs for which the function is defined
and the inputs here these are T and it
represents days and if I input T the
number of days into the function H it'll
output the height of the plant so let's
think about it at first you might say
think in terms of you know 0 days 1 days
2 days and you might be tempted to say
integers but why not think about one and
a half days or three point one seven
five days so I don't see any root not
any reason why T couldn't be a subset of
real numbers why you can think about you
know the the ninety ninety seven point
nine ninth day so I would say real
numbers and I say defined the interval
of the domain so T let's see the the T
would be defined up to two days before
she bought the plant so I would say
that's T is equal to negative two all
the way to ninety eight days and T could
be equal to negative two that would be
two days before she bought it or as high
as 98 so let's think about it so the
interval I would include I would include
negative two I would include the the low
point so that's why I'm using the
brackets if I wanted T to be greater
than not greater than or equal to I
would do the parenthesis but since T
could be equal to negative two I'm gonna
use the brackets and at the high end
it's 98 and we're going to include 98 so
I'm going to put the brackets there as
well so T would be a member of real
numbers such that it is a member of this
of this interval right over here so
negative T could be T could be negative
two but okay I guess you say negative
two is going to be less than or equal to
t which
is going to be less than or equal to 98
let's check our answer
got it right